[موسيقى]
dodj لا توجد أسواق أخرى للعلامة التجارية قوة حصانية ،
هذه العلامات التجارية الأخرى بشكل كبير تجذبك
بفوائد عملية
موثوقية في توفير الوقود وموثوقية أمان تهرب من المكالمات إليك من خلال
[موسيقى
] Dodge Challenger daemon 840
حصانًا بقوة 6.2 لتر ومقاعد ركاب فائقة الشحن من 8 أسطوانات على شكل
عجلات.
الشاحنة
وشريط السحب هو المكان الذي تضيء فيه هذه السيارة
الإطارات الصحيحة ،
والسائق الأيمن ، والمسار اللزج الأيمن ، وقد قاتل الشيطان من
صفر إلى 60 في 2.3 ثانية ،
ما الذي يشبه الذهاب من 0 إلى 60 في 2.3
ثانية
، لن أعرف أن ذلك يستغرق
سيارة مجردة وسائق محترف
يعملان بمفردهما ، لكن الأمر الأكثر
إثارة للإعجاب هو أن هذه السيارة
قانونية تمامًا للشوارع
بالكاد أفضل طريقة لوصف
شعورها على الطريق مثل هذا لأن
التعليق الأمامي رائع للغاية
عند السحب  قطاع غريب نوعًا ما على الطريق ،
فإن المكافأة الحقيقية لكل
هذه الشياطين المتحدية البالغ عددها 3300 قد
أشعلت شرارة سباق على منافسي المراوغة من
جميع الأنواع كانت المحركات الكبيرة ن.  بعد الآن دودج
في طريقها لبيع المزيد من المنافسين هذا
العام أكثر من أي وقت مضى
وأعتقد أن دخان الإطارات لا يزال يبدو جيدًا
[موسيقى]